CRIME NOT SEEN SINCE WORLD WAR
II.
THIS COMING JUST HOURS AFTER THE
MEETING WITH THE RUSSIAN FOREIGN
MINISTER SERGEY LAVROV IN
TURKEY.
JOINING ME NOW IS A MEMBER OF
THE UKRAINIAN PARLIAMENT, WHO
HAS STAYED IN KYIV, IN THE KYIV
REGION, TO HELP INFORM THE WORLD
OF THE HORRORS OF THE WAR.
WE'RE SO HAPPY TO HAVE YOU HERE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR JOINING
US.
THE RUSSIANS ARE APPROACHING
KYIV FROM DIFFERENT DIRECTIONS.
NEW VIDEO IS SHOWING FIGHTING
INTENSIFYING NEARBY.
WHAT'S IT LIKE IN YOUR CITY NOW?
>> WELL, IT IS TENSE, OF COURSE,
AS IT HAS BEEN FROM THE DAY ONE
OF THE WAR.
WE DON'T KNOW WHETHER THE
RUSSIANS WILL ACTUALLY GET INTO
THE CITY.
WE DO GET DIFFERENT NEWS BECAUSE
ON THE ONE HAND, THEY HAVE HAD
FIGHTING ON THE CITY WITH BUCHA
COMPLETELY DEVASTATED.
AND WE HAVE IMAGES OF PEOPLE
TRYING TO ESCAPE FROM THOSE
CITIES.
NOW THEY SEEM TO BE COMING FROM
THE NORTHEAST, WHICH IS A
DIFFERENT DIRECTION.
THERE HAVE BEEN SOME BATTLES
YESTERDAY OVER THERE.
THE UKRAINIAN ARMY ACTUALLY DID
MAKE A GOOD FIGHT, AND THEN MANY
RUSSIAN CONVOYS WERE ACTUALLY
STOPPED AND KILLED.
BUT THERE ARE MANY MORE COMING.
SO, WE ARE FULLY AWARE THAT THEY
CAN COME INTO THE CITY ANY TIME.
SKPF THAT IS VERY SCARY
PERSPECTIVE.
DESPITE THE CITY HAS BEEN
FORTIFIED BASICALLY WITH
TERRITORIAL DEFENSE WITH THE
CHECK POINTS AND ALL, THERE ARE
JUST TOO MANY OF THEM.
AND IT'S JUST SCARY TO IMAGINE
WHAT THEY CAN DO TO OUR CITY.
>> I WANT TO PUT UP THIS PICTURE
OF YOU WORKING WITH YOUR RIFLE
IN THE BACKGROUND.
YOU HAVE FRIENDS AND FAMILY WITH
THE ARMY.
AS YOU INFORM THE WORLD OF THE
HORRORS OF THIS WAR BUT REMAIN
READY TO FIGHT.
BASED ON WHAT WE HAVE SEEN IN
OTHER UKRAINIAN CITIES, DO YOU
THINK IT COULD COME TO THAT, YOU
ACTUALLY PICKING UP A GUN AND
YOU ACTUALLY HAVE TO FIGHT?
>> YOU KNOW, I'M A UNIVERSITY
PROFESSOR.
THAT IS NOT SOMETHING I EXPECTED
TO HAVE EVER IN MY LIFE.
THAT IS WHAT MY LIFE IS RIGHT
NOW.
FOR TWO WEEKS I HAVEN'T SEEN MY
SON.
HE'S WITH FAMILY IN THE WESTERN
UKRAINE.
I HAVEN'T SEEN MY BOYFRIEND.
HE'S WITH THE ARMY.
I HAVEN'T SEEN MY PARENTS
BECAUSE MY MOM IS IN WESTERN
UKRAINE AND MY DAD IS WITH THE
TERRITORIAL DEFENSE HELPING
EVACUATE PEOPLE.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT CAN HAPPEN.
IF SOMEONE TOLD ME THREE WEEKS
AGO THAT THIS WOULD BE MY LIFE,
I WOULD NEVER BELIEVE.
BUT THIS IS WHAT WE TURN TO.
I AM NOW USING MY VOICE AS A
WEAPON.
I AM TALKING TO THE WORLD AND
EXPLAINING WHAT IS HAPPENING
HERE IN UKRAINE AND WHY WE NEED
TO HELP IN TERMS OF SECURING OUR
SKY AND ENSURING THE NO FLY
ZONE.
BUT IF THAT DOESN'T WORK, IF THE
WORLD DOES NOT REACT AND DOES
NOT HELP US, WHAT ELSE IS THERE
FOR ME TO DO?
I CANNOT JUST LEAVE MY CITY.
I CANNOT LEAVE MY PEOPLE.
I CANNOT ALLOW THE RUSSIANS TO
TAKE OVER.
I'VE BEEN BUILDING MY LIFE HERE
IN KYIV FOR OVER 20 YEARS.
I'VE SEEN WHAT THEY HAVE DONE TO
MY NATIVE CITY OF KHARKIV, WHERE
I SPENT 17 YEARS.
THEY JUST BOMBARDED IT,
BASICALLY TURNED IT INTO A LAMP
POT, WITH THE HOLD WORLD JUST
PRETENDING NOT SEEING WHAT IS
HAPPENING THERE.
WHAT ELSE IS THERE FOR ME TO DO?
I DON'T REALLY SEE A CHOICE.
>> THE 9-YEAR-OLD YOU MENTIONED,
YOU HAVEN'T SEEN HIM SINCE THE
WAR BEGAN.
YOU SHARED THIS PICTURE HE DREW.
IT SAYS, NO FLY ZONE.
I CAN'T IMAGINE HOW DIFFICULT IT
IS TO EXPLAIN TO A CHILD WHY
THEIR LIFE WAS COMPLETELY
UPENDED AND MOM NEEDS TO BE
AWAY.
WHAT DO YOU SAY TO HIM?
>> THAT WAS PROBABLY THE MOST
DIFFICULT PART OF THE LAST TWO
WEEKS.
WHEN I HAD TO CALL HIM -- I
WASN'T CALLING HIM THE FIRST
THREE DAYS OF THE WAR BECAUSE I
NEEDED TO STAY PUT.
AND THEN THE FOURTH DAY, HE
CALLED ME AND WE CHATTED.
AND HE SAID, MOM, WHEN WILL I
SEE YOU AGAIN?
AND THAT'S WHEN I STARTED CRYING
BECAUSE I DIDN'T KNOW HOW TO
ANSWER THAT QUESTION AND WHEN I
WILL BE ABLE TO SEE HIM AGAIN.
SO, THEN I SAID I WILL CALL HIM
BACK.
AND IN A FEW HOURS I GOT MYSELF
TOGETHER AND I GOT READY FOR THE
TALK.
AND I EXPLAINED TO HIM THAT THE
WAR IS HAPPENING AND THAT
CHILDREN ARE SITTING IN THE
BUNKERS AND THAT THE RUSSIANS
ARE THROWING BOMBS ON THEIR
HEADS.
AND HE ASKED ME, IS THERE ANY
WAY THAT WE CAN PROTECT THOSE
CHILDREN?
HE GOT REALLY SCARED.
HE'S COMPLETELY FREAKED OUT BY
THE VERY IDEA OF SOMEBODY DYING.
AND NOW WHEN IT'S SO REAL, HE
GOT COMPLETELY FREAKED OUT.
AND I EXPLAINED THAT WE CAN
PROTECT THE SKY WITH, YOU KNOW,
WITH THE KIND OF SUPPORT FROM
THE AIRPLANES AND OTHER.
AND HE'S LIKE, OH, WE SHOULD
BUILD A ROOF.
AND THAT'S WHAT HE DREW ON THE
PICTURE.
BUT HE DID COVER THE SUN UNDER
THE ROOF, SO IT'S SLIGHTLY
WRONG.
>> HE WANTS THE SUNSHINE TO COME
IN.
WE CAN'T BLAME HIM FOR THAT.
>> YEAH, I DO TOO.
BUT THIS IS HOW HE FEELS.
AND HE KEEPS ASKING ME, MOM, HOW
ARE THE KIDS IN THE UNDERGROUND
STATIONS IN KHARKIV.
HE DREW ANOTHER PICTURE, BUT I
DIDN'T POST THAT ONE.
BUT HE WAS PARTICULARLY ATTACHED
WITH KHARKIV BECAUSE HE KNOWS
THAT'S MY NATIVE CITY, SO I WAS
TALKING TO HIM A LOT ABOUT THAT.
BUT THEN I'M ALSO FEELING LUCKY
THAT HE'S SAFE AND HE'S NOT
WAKING UP TO BOMBS EVERY NIGHT
LIKE OTHER CHILDREN.
>> DO YOU WORRY THAT -- BUT DO
YOU WORRY -- I'M SORRY.
HE'S ALIVE BUT WHAT DID YOU SAY?
I'M SORRY.
>> HE'S ALIVE AND I'M READING
NEWS ABOUT OTHER CHILDREN NOT
WAKING UP IN THE MORNING.
AND THAT IS JUST TERRIFYING.
THAT IS THE MOST SCARY THING FOR
A PARENT TO THINK ABOUT.
I WAS READING ABOUT A MAN WHO
WAS TRYING TO ESCAPE FROM BUCHA,
AND TWO OF HIS CHILDREN WERE
KILLED DURING THE EVACUATION.
AND HIS WIFE.
AND THAT IS SOMETHING I CAN'T
EVEN THINK ABOUT HOW MUCH PAIN
HE'S IN.
SO, I MISS MY SON, BUT I'M LUCKY
THAT HE'S SAFE AND WELL.
AND SO BY BOYFRIEND AND MY
PARENTS.
>> DO YOU WORRY THAT YOUR SON
MAY NEVER BE ABLE TO RETURN TO
HIS HOME IN KYIV?
>> I DO.
YES.
IT IS A REAL CHANCE.
I WAS THINKING WHETHER I SHOULD
PROBABLY TRY TO FIND SOME SPOT
FOR HIM TO GO TO SCHOOL IN
EUROPE.
I DON'T KNOW.
I DON'T WANT TO DO THAT.
I STILL HOPE THAT THERE CAN BE A
RATHER RELATIVELY QUICK SOLUTION
OF KICKING RUSSIANS OUT.
BUT THAT FRANKLY NOW DEPENDS ON
THE LEVEL OF SUPPORT WE SHALL
GET FROM THE WEST.
SO, YES, I AM WORRIED.
I AM WORRIED AND I DON'T WANT --
HIS SCHOOL IS HERE.
HIS FRIENDS HERE.
HE'S MISSING HIS TOYS.
HE'S ASKING IF I CAN TRANSFER
SOME OF THE TOYS TO HIM, BUT
IT'S IMPOSSIBLE RIGHT NOW.
I WANT HIM TO HAVE HIS LIFE
BACK.
THERE IS NO GOOD REASON FOR HIM
NOT HAVING HIS LIFE.
JUST CRAZY MAN DECIDING HE CAN
INVADE ANOTHER STATE WITH NO
GOOD REASON.
>> WHAT'S HIS NAME?
>> MARTIN.
WELL, YOU KNOW, WE HOPE THAT YOU
AND MARTIN AND YOUR ENTIRE
FAMILY STAY SA